[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome back
to honest trailer commentaries we got a
new episode for you this week um but it
might feel old and familiar because it's
about the matrix four
a movie about how everything is old and
familiar and why even bother um
we're gonna be talking about our uh our
more detailed thoughts about the film i
haven't really had a chance to open up
the floor and have a forum about this
movie yet so we'll do that live we're
also going to show you some deleted
scenes uh answer some viewer questions
and comments so put those in the chat
and we'll get to them at the end and
then we'll tease you with next week's
honest trailer you know the deal brand
new year same old show um and same old
same old is is the attitude that i got
from the matrix four resurrections uh
which prompted me to ask the question do
you have to make a movie um well they
want watoski answers that question in
this movie i know jonathan has a line of
dialogue when he spells out they were
gonna make this it was like with you or
without you we're making matrix
there's a lot of about this movie that i
like and i did like the um
self-referential metaness to an extent i
thought it was clever what they did to
open the film but it kept going it was
like the first half was so meta and so
relentlessly self-referential that it
didn't when the the movie started when
it was like all right we get what's
happening like we need to go back in and
rescue trendy that felt really rushed
and muddled and unsatisfying to me um
like they they shouldn't have
masturbated that long
otherwise it just gets raw and
unpleasurable for everybody right but
what what what do you think well i know
you like this one a lot more than this
right yeah i i like this uh
with the caveat i understand like i
understand why people were disappointed
i get why if you were a huge fan of the
first movie especially but even the
previous trilogy why this would feel
like it's such a different take and it's
going in such a different direction and
it really does
in terms of the action it obviously that
feels just like de-prioritized in every
way like in the original the first one
especially but also like reloaded it's
got that crazy
freeway stuff yeah yeah it was just
obviously like that was a central focus
of the movie is like the wire work and
capturing that hong kong
style and like
not a focus this time i think famously
uh lon that that they famously sold the
movie to will smith and the reason he
passed was all they just kept talking
about was bullet time purely bullet time
and like it's obvious when you watch the
movie like they're thinking of this in
terms of like how it's going to look and
the aesthetic and the action and
everything else sort of came from there
and this one is such a different take
it's really more of a sci-fi comedy
romance than an action film and
like i get i like that i don't mind
there's plenty of action films i'm happy
for the matrix to be this other thing
but i do get why it's more like a review
of the matrix four while you're watching
the matrix and i get why there would be
a lot of people who you're expecting to
come in for a new matrix movie and
you're like it's going to be the matrix
again and then yeah literally keanu
doesn't pick up a gun it you know most
of the action is like force field
throwing at you and you know like it
just feels de-emphasized in favor of
the comedy and the meta stuff and the
more satirical thoughtful material about
reboots and franchise culture how'd you
feel about that danielle i i i felt like
they were writing the trailer that we
were writing like as i'm watching it i'm
like oh you got you don't take all the
jokes
leave something on the table for us we
have to do our job um yeah like it's i i
don't know i think i went into it with
such low expectations that like it
couldn't have
and the the the bar was already on the
floor so watching it i was like yeah
like this is fine like i like it but i
you know i guess for some people if you
went into it thinking you know the first
matrix blew my mind and this is going to
blow my mind there are no minds blown
like it's oh you know like it's just
fine um some people were old makeup i
liked that we had broadway boys duel off
you know but other than that yeah it was
just you know hot smith hot smith's
great good you know good good on you
yeah you mentioned like lowering the bar
and that was i feel like why i like and
don't like this movie because um
the
bar was so low because it's like okay
she got to do what she wanted to do with
this movie lana wachowski got to do
exactly the remake she wanted of a thing
that i think
is pretty clear she did not want to
remake or revisit in the first place or
if she was she was just going to spend
the whole time giving the middle finger
to
the studio that made it and the audience
that cares about it explicitly i think
this movie comes from a place of like
she's not interested in going back to
the world of the originals and like
revisiting that again like as a mission
statement that was like not what she
wanted to do she wanted to come in and
like reinvent it in this totally new way
and like i think that's cool and
interesting but i i understand like
that's that it does go very against
where a lot of these franchises are
going which is
more into the heart of fan fanservice
and celebrating the legacy and you know
all that like we're going to bring back
everything you like and recreate all
these classic moments and this is like
no no what if we totally upended every
expectation and did the opposite and
like the one thing i would say like in
real praise of this is
uh bound the the wachowski's
film is really funny and the first
matrix is actually pretty funny and then
their movies kind of started to get less
funny like speed racer i think you can
maybe is like sort of an outlier but
this is funny like this feels much more
like that loose kind of like quippy
early wachowski writing style which i
really appreciate it like i thought this
was a fun time even though it doesn't
really feel like a matrix booth yeah
well fair enough um i think there's much
more to say uh mostly on the maravingian
and how we needed more maravin
but let's also the new morpheus i feel
like we could have done a whole trailer
just about that i was into new morpheus
all right roll roll it be honest for
matrix 4 resurrections
[Music]
from the company that distributes hbo
max content in theaters and one of the
minds behind jupiter ascending now bees
are genetically designed to recognize
royalty
sure comes in installments
i mean that movie is very funny um i
think like pretty much start to finish
is
is humorous whether that was intentional
or not all right it's a different kind
it's a different kind of funny because i
do and i think it's purposeful like
jupiter ascending is supposed to be like
big and and over the top and cartoonish
in that way but uh but yeah it's a
different kind it's like it's like a
dryly funny sort of more more like a
snarky kind of bunny
early
as opposed to the you know absurdity of
jupiter
the line i like dogs is always like come
on
i like dogs i like hugs um
i uh and just referring to um
lily wachowski not being a part of this
film i looked into it and she's just
like i'm tired and then that's fair
that came across from lana and but i
guess i guess it's even well it's a good
thing lily didn't uh come on board
because she's just like i just made two
huge uh big budget sci-fi you know soap
opera epic films that you know had also
had mixed perceptions like i don't want
to do this again um i
go go ahead if it has to happen enjoy
have fun with your toys they had almost
opposite sort of comments like lily had
said you know
this is an old thing we did it i feel
like it's done i want to do new stuff
i'm not interested and the lana was like
i really missed neo and trinity i can't
wait to do more stuff with it it was
like really interesting how that you
have to when you're doing press for the
movie you made you can't be like well
no i don't think she was just blowing
smoke she's very much speaking her mind
about all of this stuff i don't know
there was a i'll have to dig it up there
was a red carpet uh interview with her
where they're like why
uh why now why bring the matrix back now
and she's like
oh
good question
but i i agree with that but i also think
you can't tell that her love for these
characters does i think come through in
this movie like like it is dismissive of
sequels and the matrix is a concept and
i feel like especially one of the things
that she's grappling with and this is
how it like it got away from them like
they created the matrix it had meaning
for them and uh now it's just become
this like catch-all for everybody's
everything and it's been used to express
every possible idea and philosophy and
trope including some we don't have to
get like some sort of negative ones and
i think that this was a response to that
as well of like reclaiming it and like
you know it got it got so diffuse and
like no it's mine like i created this
and i get to say what it is yep
uh all right let's keep going i think
we'll we'll get into that later this is
what technology looked like when the
last one came out freeman 713 i'm a
signal
matrix
prepare for a film that asks the
ultimate question do you take the blue
pill and let them reboot this without
the creators starring tom holland as neo
or take the red pill and see how far up
its own ass the story can go this cannot
be another reboot retread regurgitation
why not i will sequel franchise enough
at last
i wasn't too sure about the callback but
you know that's it hard to resist as
matrix four yeah i loved new morpheus
which i did not expect um i i did not
think that but i guess he was also agent
smith at the same time it's a
i mean he's yeah he's a he's a is an
algorithm based on the combination of
like morpheus's brain but agent smith's
like john description and i liked him so
much in the matrix but i can't believe
they did it again where half the movie
not half them
saw too much of the movie takes place
outside of the matrix where they're in a
cave they're talking about strawberries
and they're just going blah blah blah
blah blah
and he's made with one of those like he
spencer's gifts desks
one of the man of steel like krypton
robot things and like yeah again man um
obviously
uh the matrix is better than what's it
called now it's not zion anymore
yeah yeah let's stay away from there
um i don't know like i did i'm i'm glad
we got to check out the new sort of like
version of that world and i did really
like the bit where uh there's like
robots are working with humans now so
there's just like some of the squid guys
are our friends and there's that little
like non-racist transformer looking guy
thankfully not racist like his
transformer buddies uh
hanging out on the desk you know just
giving people high fives like job well
done like i thought that was really fun
yeah it's a cute idea but again i think
that there probably would have been
that would have hit uh harder if they
hadn't spent the first 45 minutes to an
hour of the movie just like inside the
matrix talking about the franchise films
known as the matrix definitely has some
weird pacing stuff also io really needs
to work on its prison system because
they just put you in this tower with a
big window but everybody has spaceships
yeah
that's not this is not an effective this
is not an effect of jailing i liked the
cute droids
i did what i mean like
like you you give me a cute little robot
pet i'm going to be involved i don't
know it looked like big old headlights
or something that was not i did not find
any of them too i think there's so much
imagination and creativity here to spare
that it's like i kind of found it
irresistible even though like i you know
like it's it's weird and absurd and
doesn't always feel matrixy
all right let's keep going
first double mind
a movie about being forced to make a
follow-up to a trilogy you're currently
watching the forced follow-up to which
just ends up being reality our beloved
parent company warner brothers has
decided to make a sequel to the trilogy
they informed me they're gonna do it
with or without us it's like they
invented bulletin but for dodging
criticism
yeah we said it first you can't say it
we said it
i forgot how the matrix ended
no the other ones look look
just look at that
pick off 60 years after neo became
computer jesus and brought an end to the
war between robot squids and cave ravers
and while in matrix coffees have become
extremely tiny not much has changed for
the billions still stuck inside the
matrix is the same or wars but nia won't
return to shut it down for good or
awaken the millions who still want to be
free no instead watch the chosen one
risk at all
i mean there was like it was kind of a
cynical
message i guess uh
where
i think they were implying that people
don't want to leave the matrix like
even more in this version they're like
even happier in there because it's like
run by human emotion rather than like
well i was a little confused by what the
analyst had done to change the matrix
right it's it's that he's focusing
rather than precision like the the
architect to design the matrix like
mathematically
using like data
and the analyst was like allowing people
to like
determine their own loops or whatever
was like allowing people more like
creative freedom or mental sort of
flexibility while still keeping them in
prison but the secret to the whole thing
is that it's powered by the love of
trinity and neo when they're kept like
so close yeah edging and i don't think
that that specifically i don't think is
ever fully unpacked it's just like their
power is they're they're
being together in their love gotcha like
the one is now the one relationship yeah
and like that's the whole or so
whatever
interesting idea um i just don't know if
that was like
i don't know that was given a chance to
be like dramatized or like enacted in
the story rather than he just tells you
that that's how things are working it's
always been a talky kind of series i
mean the first not the first one not the
i mean the first one hid it so well they
found a half hour where lawrence
fishburne just tells you what is going
on but they also at the same time like
they do show it like they do like even
as he's talking it's not so much like
what the architect is just like
morpheus at least like they show you
they put you into like the negative zone
and guns are flying past you or it's
like take this pill or this pill like
they found ways to make it more engaging
and have like a visual component to it i
think you're wrong there's a scene in
the matrix where they're literally in a
white void watching the backstory on a
television like which was interesting
that's visually interesting i'm sorry
but that is that was that's the ex
that's like the least you can possibly
do to cover exposition no then that's
the
architect is that they just watch the
exposition on tv and there's nothing
else to even look at yeah i think i'm
not it's a good movie i'm not trying to
say that the original is bad i just it's
always been a a talky let's tell you
what's happening kind of thing this is
true um but sometimes you do it with
both of your arms crossed behind you and
i guess i mean i'm talking my way into
uh into agreeing with some of the
choices uh because it's like again if
the architect made the matrix and it was
like very precise and ordered and
controlled then it made sense why it was
kind of like a like an old school
computer monitor and everything was kind
of tinted green and either like dirty or
dark and this one just looked like a cw
show
like as like a soap opera which i get i
guess okay i get it if that's
intentional but it also makes for like
an unpleasant like what is this cheap
crap movie experience it is i i agree
with everything you're saying it is
intentional i think because yeah it's
like it's a world powered by literally
love like that of course it looks glossy
and like romanticized or whatever but it
does like when you first watch it you're
like
is this the netflix
not enough green i need more green it is
pretty wide and i mean it's doing
there's a she's making a lot of like
random aesthetic choices that are just
to like set it apart like the original
matrix series you never really know what
city they're in it's really not
specified it's just like rainy and lots
of buildings and it's like kind of every
city usa or whatever and this one it's
always like san francisco now they're in
paris we're going to tokyo like they're
super specific always you know like
where they are and like there's just
like a lot of stuff that i think she
purposefully did just to like
mix it up yeah all right keep going
who eat his girlfriend if there is a
chance i can free her even if it means
endangering everyone in this city
because we're finally getting the answer
to what the franchise was really about
taking unlabeled pills then risking it
all to impress a girl you met online
yeah
why do all my trinities look like harry
knowles
keanu reeves and his struggle beard
return as thomas anderson a game
designer who probably should have taken
over cyberpunk 2077 until he's reborn
again as neo again
a living legend who's treated with the
reverence of a modern day keanu reeves
not uh fanboy out here but this is kind
of a huge moment for me joining him is
trinity who's back to kicking ass and
taking names two hours into the run time
my name is trinity
there she is newcomer bugs the latest
example of warner brothers space jamming
their ips into everything my name
in bunny what's up duck
uh simulated version i really liked bugs
and then she kind of disappeared she
kind of just
gets sidelined um
i get it uh neo and trendy are the are
the core of the story but like
you still leave this you know uh
with neo trinity and morpheus being the
standout characters and i guess naughty
and you lose agent smith as a standout
character but like they couldn't give us
one new where's the french twins you
know where's the weird albino dreadlock
french twins of this movie
where are they yeah i feel like jessica
hedwig is like forever doomed to like be
cool characters that get set up to go
somewhere good and then we never get the
follow-up this is like iron fist also
ends with a really promising potential
future for colleen wing that we're
almost definitely never going to get to
see no well she might because she took
this movie over something else i think
explicitly
yeah to preserve
uh the chance of coming back as uh
calling wing which why not yeah
kingpin's back screw it could happen
yeah
um
and they did but yeah i also i also like
i i like bugs in this i thought that was
probably the best view character yeah i
did laugh that they brought back the
maravingian
the absolute madman
the
the best slash worst part of the sequels
for the bad accuracy
yeah like no orgasm cake no thank you
that actually is what she's having paul
verhoeven's uh benedetta one of the like
oh he's the the
the
slimy uh yes he's the italian guy yeah
right he's the sort of representative of
the of the pope or whatever yeah
and uh it took me like half the movie to
be like wow i'm just you're watching me
realize that live who's that guy who was
that guy and then i'd like it he'd be
like oh it's a very veggie okay
uh also a good movie you guys should
watch the uh benedetto if you haven't
yet uh okay keep playing of morpheus
because the real one canonically died in
the bad 2005 video game
can't bring back the best part of the
films if he died in a video game tie-in
that'd just be crazy niobee the
character from the good matrix video
game tie-in and i guess the sequels
agent smith who's been upgraded into a
hot musical theater actor but who brings
as much menace to the role as he did to
king george in hamilton awesome wow some
robo scab class traders
i'm sorry
he couldn't get hugo back for
anything
doesn't like to come back
i guess he didn't do uh yeah not a red
skull anymore right yeah he's kind of
one of them only moves forward he never
goes back yeah but like i guess that
they were
you know i thought it was funny uh that
they made like the new agent smith like
a programmer and like the the real enemy
of it all was like silicon valley bro
culture but when you but at some point
you got to start punching each other and
i just what jonathan gruff
you sir and neither i mean probably hugo
weaving couldn't either i don't know he
probably wasn't doing his own uh fight
choreo was he
back in the day maybe some some of the
close-up stuff but no probably not yeah
i just got to see it when you when you
see just a bunch of musical theater
actors kung fu in each other it just
doesn't hit the same as that initial uh
matrix movie i i like that the the one
of the big final fights was literally
you know patrick harris versus jonathan
grump again
if that i feel like this is the litmus
test for this movie if you can say okay
we're we've we're leaving the matrix in
her action era and we're picking her up
in her romantic sci-fi adventure era
then great you can accept it and it's
fun and it's goofy and it works but yeah
if you're still looking for
you know the lobby fight or the i know
kung fu bit from the first movie like
well the problem is this is the favorite
movie it's on blu-ray now they're right
in that that brainstorming session which
is like the matrix was all things to all
people and like the great thing is you
didn't have to choose in the first one
you know you got your romance sketch
drama got traction got your philosophy
you know it was like a total package it
was a complete a fully formed story and
movie and film and everything it gave
you everything you wanted and yeah maybe
what's that four quadrants maybe yeah
four questions maybe uh so
it was an impossible task to recreate
that i mean they tried and i think
failed though they weren't complete
failures but they didn't the sequels
didn't fully capture that and i don't
know i i'm not saying i totally love the
sequels either but they also were like
kind of an attempt to like the
wachowskis are like they're they're the
hugo weavings of directors like they
don't want to repeat themselves and it
was always like that was a real hard
left from where we thought the matrix
was you know one ends with neo superman
now and he's going to free everybody
from the matrix and then two or three
are like forget everybody in the matrix
we're about zion now and like we're
focused on the real world and this war
between machines and humans and it is a
real difference and i think people did
react to the sequels negatively because
of that in some ways yeah
yeah that's just like another turn it's
just not a u-turn we're still going
somewhere different yeah
well i just think that it uh even like
you said in the second one uh like that
freeway sequence and in the third one
their attempt at it with like the battle
of zion is that there was an attempt to
do something with the
craft of action filmmaking in addition
to everything else that they just
completely bailed on here yeah they're
all still action movies and the third
one is like this this like war dystopian
post-apocalyptic war film really yeah
okay keep playing class traders who all
look like these thingies and neil
patrick harris as the analyst a clear
metaphor for the fact that men do not
need therapy in fact i am the chosen one
and that married woman i'm obsessed with
does love me she just doesn't know it
yet okay i did my own research
yeah i like that they tried
like put the red pill thing to bed like
the red pill is not what you think it is
guys and then they introduced like but
the bad guy in all of this he's a
therapist he's your therapist is trying
to control you the movie is pretty like
unambiguously anti-therapy
it's hard to find a way around it like
don't listen to your therapist don't
listen to your therapist
yeah you're delusions of grandeur
they're correct um dump out all your
pills it's totally about all your pills
they're trying to control you they're
just holding you back man
you can fly you got powers all that kind
of stuff um
yeah anyways keep going you loved the
first matrix for its original mix of
william gibson's neuromancer with a gap
khakis commercial now all that
meticulous craft will be sidelined for
the same quick-cut garbage fighting
that's numbed us out for the last decade
augmented by effects that are supposed
to look fake and bad i guess and where
neo still knows kung fu but at this age
he'd just rather spam the block button
come on you have john wick in your movie
and that's the director of john wick
would it kill you to wick it up a bit
wiki wiki kiki kiki
so pause yeah that is chad
um playing the character of chad
see what you did there god it's so meta
um
but yeah
i don't know do you think keanu just
doesn't want to do that anymore like he
doesn't want to he's already doing five
john wicks i don't think it's keanu i
think that was a that was 100 lana
wachowski saying it's not an action film
focus thing anymore we'll do some action
scenes because because that's what we
got to do but yeah we're doing this
other thing now it feels very purposeful
not i don't know i think that there were
two
sequences the bullet train and the um
the ending with the you know the suicide
bombers or whatever you want to call
them but that were like on paper
supposed to be groundbreaking action
scenes but in practice weren't i mean
that final scene is cool with the with
the like swarm people attack like i
still think it's a cool sequence like
while granting that it's not as visually
impressive and groundbreaking and
intricately choreographed i mean that's
the number one thing it feels like the
original matrix fights are very like
choreographed like it's very specific
and this it feels like you know what we
get with a lot of modern action where it
just feels like we're seeing a lot of
edited together kicks and punches and it
all kind of vaguely suggests action but
it's not as tight yeah and uh yeah i
mean i don't think it was keanu reeves
saying i don't feel like doing that i
think it was lana which asks saying you
know we're gonna we're gonna have this
totally different aesthetic yeah all
right
fine we'll we'll fix it in matrix five
and six uh okay keep going so gather the
adult children you've had time to raise
since the matrix came out and revisit a
film stuffed with about 100 references
to a timeless classic free your mind mr
anderson
time is always against us
etc etc and two or three references from
the sequels and this self-aware shrug of
defiance towards franchise filmmaking
that got trounced at the box office
because two rival studios released six
different spider-mans starring three
different actors then reunited them on
screen before the m4 tricks could even
come out sorry neo you're too late we've
all been spider pilled
i mean what a
what a what a wild state of affairs that
um that could happen in between the
third and fourth matrix uh which i think
that this movie is like the
anti-spider-man no way home and well
we see where the public sympathies live
it's weird because it you know obviously
the movies were not made in conversation
with each other at all but they do feel
like opposite sides of an argument of
like no no the thing to do is to come up
with a new story that perfectly weaves
everything people love from all the old
stories into the news story and versus
like forget the old story it was dumb
we're doing this now yeah it's like
i want to see i wish they had flipped
though i wish that the new spider-man
movie was like spider-man is stupid and
you're nostalgia electro what's wrong
with you but that's what we're doing is
throwing girls off buildings
you know they just put everyone back in
the leather suits and did more bullet
time um i i don't know why i think i
feel like that would have worked better
we got tank back but nobody thought tank
was coming back i want to see uh joey
pants eating steak and yeah yeah eating
various there is a shot of keanu eating
steak uh like something yeah
they do get a cipher [ __ ] but no i want
to see the movie that joey pants stars
in you know once he's been plugged back
into the matrix but no he's dead now uh
whatever we'll we'll build him again you
could retcon that yeah uh i mean you
know who else was dead neo and trinity
very clearly trinity
not ambiguous like
yeah
uh okay let's finish this up it's about
ethics and gaming symbolism deus ex mac
on her yeah yeah i know i'm not lawrence
fishburne but give me a chance the
defenders antivirus dark clippy
you know weaving whoa is that christina
richie for one scene jada packet smith
and when you finally buy a bidet i got a
hack in the bathroom hurry yes
[Music]
the great trend robbery
pretty cool that the two big villains
are both musical theater icons when are
we getting the matrix on broadway
kristin chenoweth is the oracle that guy
who played shrek as the architect oh and
ben platt is the spoon kid he's the
perfect age
um there are there are two people uh in
this world um people who have a bidet
and get that joke and people who don't i
need to get one
you know who you are
uh all right um that was fun i think we
have a good amount of deleted scenes for
this i believe and if they're ready to
go let's roll right into those
starring
the oh needer
john click
one note man the ip man tiff dweller
cycle ex-girlfriend
the other one
the two
trinity gritty
looper trooper
hackmanta what is it with this guy in
mirrors
acid burn
what's real doc doogie browser how you
met your maker legend wait for it boring
can we have a new season of mine hunter
please nioh b movie
dread leader standing by
jada wrinkled smith
hashtag gamer fate
computer love
the sims busting out
the matrix regrets
actually meta
hey you know that cover version of the
rage against the machine song at the end
is pretty nice i should check that band
out
[Music]
nevermind thank you danielle
yep yep yep if someone's gonna spot the
girl pen yeah i did not i i did not
recognize brass against uh from their
music i don't know how that happened
yeah i mean that really sums it up for
me is like
a cover version of the matrix one and um
different
for me worse but certainly i can see how
other people would like it the same or
better but uh it also piece all over you
and also pees on somebody's face
one lucky fan got brought live
what's the consent like on that like do
they are is she like i'm gonna pee on
you and he's like yeah or yes my
understanding was was that she was
saying that she really needed to use the
bathroom and she asked for a volunteer
and then dude came up and got his whole
life
that's my understanding yeah that really
you're setting yourself up for felony
charges if you're just like who wants to
sing the next song with me and then this
is like a surprise reveal you gotta let
people know close your eyes yeah before
they're coming
totally
um all right let's get into some
questions uh mj pretzel writes
everyone's wearing the same color shirt
today and i think that's nice oh look at
that uh because we're maybe in the
matrix on tuesdays we work greatly yeah
uh devon bain writes uh if it wasn't
netflix show quality action everyone
would have been more forgiving and i
agree i feel like if they had uh um
upped the ante on some of that that i
think the plot would have flown more
smoothly for everybody else no i mean i
think that that does seem to be the
number one criticism and it's like
yeah i mean it's one of those things
where i don't know if it's necessarily
like
the action here is so terrible it's just
it's like that the the marketing and
advertising doesn't live up to what it
is like it's setting up disappointment
because people think they're getting the
matrix and then they're getting
something else so i think it's one of
those ways that may benefit from
hindsight like in a few years people
might go back and with no expectations
to be like oh this was better than
people thought at the time like i feel
like i mean that certainly happened with
matrix two and three um
right
and and the prequels and a million other
things know it's like horror movies
where it's like they're not jump scare
movies but they're still interesting but
people are disappointed when they go see
them because they're expecting
jump scares and yeah i think we're
probably in the same zone
mattan valensky writes after the star
wars sequels jurassic worlds and the m4
tricks do you have a fear of the next
avatar doing meta and legacy sequels and
how will they do it i have no fear of
that james cameron only knows one
direction that's forward and downward to
the bottom of the ocean he does not look
back he's always pushing us onto the
next horizon uh there's no way avatar is
going to be a self-referential meta
thing about avatar one uh god god help
us all if it is um but yes i do think
that there's this is now like like they
said the third
long-running franchise that's now become
like this oraboros of like self-sucking
um and
that's that that's enough i don't think
anything else needs to probably marvel's
gonna end up doing it if they're pretty
meta already but um like when deadpool
shows up again or something i think
posts no way home like work we're doomed
like i think they're they're gonna
that's the lesson then yep they're gonna
learn the wrong lesson everybody is yeah
that's a good lesson they're gonna take
from no way home is oh they want grab
that which is not not that i'm saying
this is what the lesson should be or
this is what no way home does but this
is the lesson they're going to extract
from it is every movie now is like
portals where every version of every
character is meeting up with themselves
and like constant self-referential we're
it's just a whole universe of that like
i think we're in for that with every
friendship god do we have to reevaluate
ready player one again because i hate
that movie
um but please let's not but that's that
but i do think that's kind of the
template where it's like context-free
just like oh you like this thing guess
what they're all back yeah give me all
the superman's together and make him
kiss
two questions for the theme i'd watch
that
on a theme here trevor reese asks uh how
much is movie a reflection on the change
of tech in our culture tech savvy people
aren't just the leather clad ravers
anymore also mark sheridan writes was
there enough leather in the new movie is
the critical question you know i was
very surprised at how much l.l bean
catalog where there were yeah right
everyone's like casual or like the
uniqlo like clothes i was like oh it's
like casual day in the matrix like
everyone's wearing like their baggy
stuff it was nice but it was like way
comfortable
hackers have never been i mean i guess
that there is like they dress up at
raves or something like that but if they
wanted to portray hacker culture it
would be like an extra large gray
t-shirt that they got at a conference
you know for free that would be and
sweatpants no i think this is i think
this raises a great point uh which is
that when the matrix came out like when
it was new
people who were hacking or who
understood code or were writing for you
know software like working on computers
it was still like a niche thing it was a
subculture it did have a look it did
have an aesthetic it didn't have a style
but now you know
everybody in the coffee shop is working
on their app it's like it's gone
totally mainstream we've all got the new
gadget and the phone and the watch and
whatever and uh and so i think yeah it
does aesthetically reflect that that
like now suburban moms are playing the
matrix just like uh you know the kids
were in 99 yeah uh all right final uh
final question here uh bert pesci asks
um do you think this would have been
better if they lean harder into the meta
aspect of the plot like if keanu reeves
was playing keanu reeves
i don't know yeah one of
those i think that if they had
i think that the meta part either needed
to uh last sort of the length of the
film and they and like it ended with neo
leaving the matrix for the first time
and this was like part one of another
trilogy uh or just make it like the
first 10 12 minutes i really think it
was the anti-sweet spot to to be so meta
for like act one and a half uh to like
the midpoint of the movie i think that
that was too much uh but i still liked
its inclusion really
i i i think the the second thing you're
saying makes sense the first version of
it where the whole movie it's like part
one and he's in the matrix of all time
like i'm glad i'm really glad
like i don't i have no desire to see a
full movie of just the part where he's
like oh is this is this real because
because we know like the the the one
issue i think pacing wise at the
beginning of this movie is that we know
implicitly because it's a movie
that he's in a version of the matrix
like there's no point at which we're
fooled like maybe maybe he really is
just a guy named tom anderson who made a
game and he's crazy uh
so you know i i don't think you could
tease it out for quite that long and
build the suspense but uh i i liked it
and i think you know like
it is a thread that runs through the
whole thing
yeah all right
danielle final thoughts
um you know i'm just gonna uh i
let's just all go back 20 years ago and
like redo everything that we did so i'm
gonna go back to musical theater um and
i will catch y'all on the flip-flop
your timing is great it's like tick tick
boom and that's what we're all the
culture is doing that with you beautiful
all right so let's all uh regress
peacefully into the past as we lose uh
the physical digital divide and just a a
a 2004 singularity is what we're all
going for so crank that black eyed peas
um we're going back in time and we're
going to uh see you next week um
for something that's a little nostalgic
but also moves a little bit forward and
uh we'll let you know if it hits the
mark or not when we do next week's
honest trailer commentaries we'll see
you then thanks everyone bye-bye
[Music]
you